I want to start with a congratulations
on this movie
oh can you hear me yeah can you yeah
yeah I'm just going to say I sincerely I
didn't know what I was going to get when
I watched it and it's really really a
um it's an important story and it's so
well done yeah thank you I think yeah I
think it's a great film huh it's in it's
yeah it's an inspiring story yeah it's
something I wanted to touch on is that I
thought Sally did such a great job
directing with the way that I I thought
she just did a great job and can you
sort of talk about what she brought to
the table because the way she told the
story was so excellent
yeah I think her vision was like she
came up with that story that she want to
make a film about girls you know growing
up like she did when she was when she
grew up in Cairo in the 90s and you know
like uh girls fun it's it's oh it's
about it's it's ordinary people you know
and uh and um she had a vision to tell a
story about yeah about
hopes and dreams and passion you know
you are not a huge part of this movie
but you are a critical part of this
movie what is it like coming in in
essentially the third act to sort of be
you know what I mean you're a big part
of the of the third Act of a film
it's funny because we we shocked the
third act
um we shot we shot all these scenes at
the beginning of the shoot so and then
uh and then they went to to to you know
to shoot all the rest of the film so I
think I think it's it's it's a pretty
important part because when they
um reach Germany yeah and uh and like
the safe place the safe country it's
it's nice to see that they or that the
um
you know it's all about the Olympics and
the swimming and still uh you know
fulfilling her dreams and and wanted you
know to achieve something great because
of how she was raised with her dad yeah
and I kind of think it's super important
for the film because after the whole
crazy Journey
they're still you know they're survivors
human beings and she has dreams so she
fights for it and uh and I think that's
great were you sort of happy you didn't
really have to train for this movie you
know to do the swimming it's sort of
like standing on the sidelines training
them I mean you know I trained a lot to
you know I worked on my calmness and on
my smile and on being like you know a
very tolerant coach and uh yeah but no I
mean the girls they they really they
went through a tough process of swimming
and working out and uh um but you know
it's always great to to jump into
characters like this you know it's uh I
kind of like that process you've
directed a number of films um most
recently I believe Army of Thieves uh
I'm just curious you've worked uh
recently as an actor on a number of
projects in some high profile things um
what have you learned over the last few
years that you want to take with you as
a filmmaker to your future endeavors
that first is always you know about the
vision and and
you know and
and about that acting has to be real but
still
in the film you know uh you you know
what I mean and um
all for example the work with Chris
Nolan was so interesting and uh uh uh I
love him so much and um the same with
Sally because she she was so calm and so
nice and she always tried to focus on
hey how can I reach my goals by making
them Crystal Clear hey you have to let
it go and follow my vision yeah and um
uh I kind of was yeah I think that was
it was a great learning process for me
do you feel like in the last few years
or the last two three years you've sort
of won like the actors lottery in terms
of being able to do getting to work with
Nolan uh being in this big action
Netflix film that with golgo uh you know
the Millie Millie Vanilli thing like
there's just a lot going on and I'm just
wondering if you are able to sort of
appreciate oh my God you know I think
every day I try to be really thankful
because I was born in the east of
Germany and I always dreamed of you know
when the Wall came down I always dreamed
of you know
you know this big hairy goal like you
know dream big and um fight for your
dreams fight for your goals never give
up and believe in in your team and
people in in in in the stars in energy
and and
um and and to be honest I'm so happy for
what I can do now in my age you know I'm
not 25 anymore I'm 26 and it's uh it's
you know nobody you know it's I'm really
happy because it's I'm just getting
started you know and that's great that's
it's a great feeling I have to ask you
what is it like getting the phone call
from Nolan or whoever being saying we
would like you to be in a Chris Nolan
movie and you know what I mean it was so
surreal because
I did a casting for him like two years
before and I really hooked it up and I
really popped it up you know and um and
it wasn't it wasn't a good good casting
and I think I was horrible but then to
receive that call hey you're in I was so
happy but the weirdest thing was I
immediately called Hans Zimmer and told
Hans
hey or and Zack Snyder you know uh even
I called these people and told them hey
I will be in Chris's next film and
they've both been like oh my God say hi
to him
that that was that was really crazy that
was to be honest that was really really
weird
but great yeah I can't I can't imagine
well the thing that I'm most looking
forward to with that film is not only
it's a Nolan movie but I believe he shot
most of it in IMAX and I cannot wait to
see what he's cooking up yeah I mean it
looked fantastic all these actors are
amazing Kitty Murphy he was fantastic
and uh yeah even I can't wait to see the
phone I can't wait I can't wait to see
the phone I know you were involved with
this Milli Vanilli movie
um yeah uh girl you know it's true
um yeah which is for people that don't
realize it's an incredible story which I
think nowadays people have forgotten
about but can you sort of talk about
what it's about who you play because
it's a it's a crazy story I mean it's it
the movie is about the band Milli
Vanilli and and the story behind them is
that the producer I play called
frankfurion he invented this band and um
uh he he had a like a second band like a
real band who who were we the real
singers the real musicians and he found
these two good look talking dancers made
made a band of it and sold it to the
world they received a Grammy a world too
they had like three number one hits in
the world in the US in and it's it's
it's insane that everything was fake
yeah it was it was a it was fake and uh
I can't wait for the world to see that
film and I'm and I'm really and I think
I'm a really smart looking good producer
you know it's uh I have long hair the
90s that's fun
oh I really can't wait to see it either
listen I gotta stop with you I'm just
gonna say I'm really happy for you and
uh congrats on the swimmers because it's
really a fantastic and important film
see let's make this every year you know
like next time we see each other on
Heart of Stone then it will be Millie
Vanilli yeah maybe the northern one
would be great what's funny is if I had
more time I would have brought up part
of stone
um but I I'm I'm really listen there's
only so much time man I'm just gonna
again I'm really happy for you and I do
hope you're directing again soon I will
I will soon there will be news
oh and there we go on that note my
fingers knock on wood uh Hey listen man
congrats on everything and thank you for
your time